este barco de la marina china navegó
cerca de Taiwán y disparó desde su
puente después de que Beijing iniciará
tres días de ejercicios militares
alrededor de La Isla al menos 71 aviones
y nueve barcos chinos cruzaron la línea
mediana del estrecho de Taiwán que
separa el territorio chino del
territorio controlado por taipei los
medios de comunicación estatales chinos
difundieron imágenes de estos aviones de
combate la intención enviar una serie
advertencia a Taiwán según el ejército
chino la presidenta taiwanesa no tardó
en reaccionar prometiendo mantenerse
firme frente a Beijing en los últimos
años nos hemos enfrentado a una
expansionismo autoritario continuado me
gustaría reiterar que el pueblo de
Taiwán ama la democracia Busca la paz y
está dispuesto a cumplir con sus
responsabilidades con la comunidad
internacional Seguiremos trabajando con
Estados Unidos y otros países afines
para defender conjuntamente los valores
de la libertad y democracia Beijing
considera Taiwán como territorio propio
y desea recuperar su control En nombre
del principio de una sola China la
operación se produce tras la reunión de
la presidenta taiwanesa con el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos a
principios de semana que aumento las
tensiones según las autoridades
taiwanesas china tomó como excusa Esta
visita para realizar estos ejercicios
militares por su parte el ejército de
Taiwán ha dicho que vigilara de cerca
los simulacros y que procurará no crear
conflictos o escalar la situación